The first scheduling policy is a very simple
one, first come, first serve. And what this
is saying is that you look at the
order of arrival of threads into the scheduling queue
of the scheduler and pick the one that
is the earliest to become runnable again. And that's
the one that you're going to schedule. So what
this is saying is, well basically we will give
importance to fairness for threads as opposed to affinity.
So it is ignoring affinity altogether and simply saying
let's just be fair. We'll pick the thread that
became runnable at the earliest, that's the one that we're
going to pick as the next one to run on
the processor. That's first come, first served. The second
scheduling policy is called fixed processor, or in other
words, for every thread, when I schedule the thread the
first time, I'm going to pick a particular
processor. And I'm always going to stick to that.
So the processor on which Ti will run
will always be a particular fixed processor. And
the, the, the, way we choose the initial processor on which to schedule Ti may
depend on the, load balance. Making sure that
all the processors in the multiprocessor are equally
stressed in terms of, using the resources for
running the available threads that are there in the
system. And that's how I pick a particular
processor but you, for the life of this thread,
the processor on which Ti is going to run
is always fixed. So that's fixed processor scheduling. The
third scheduling policy is what is called a
last proccessor scheduling policy. The idea here is the
processor is going to pick among the set of threads
that are available to be run at any point
of time. It is going to pick a thread that
used to run on it. In other words, if TI
the last time it had any cycles from the
system was on a particular processor. Then, when this
processor is coming around looking for work, it'll see
oh, Ti is there, he used to run on me.
I'm going to pick that guy to run on me again. And
as you can imagine, this is giving preference to the fact
that there could be affinity for Ti to this processor, because
it used to run on this. So that is what is
called last processor scheduling, and of course when a processor is
looking for work and it looks at the run queue, does
not find any thread that used to run on it, and
of course it has to pick some thread, right? So the,
the inclination is to pick the thread that had
run on this processor before. And, and that's the one
that I want to schedule on P last. But
if such a thread is not available, then you're going to
pick something else. So, the idea behind this is
that, you want to make sure that if this processor
is going to pick a thread to run on it, the
likelihood of this thread finding its memory contents in this
processor is high. That's, that's what we're trying
to shoot for in this last processor. The next
couple of scheduling policies I'm going to tell you
about. It requires more sophistication in terms of the
information that the scheduler needs to keep on
behalf of every thread. You know in order to
make a scheduling decision. The next scheduling policy is
what is called minimum Intervening policy. MI for short.
And in MI, what we're going to do is the
following. We're going to keep, for every thread, it's affinity with
respect to a particular processor, and pick the processor for
running this thread in which this thread has the highest affinity.